there is a kind of uh
belief that the scarcity of a particular
resource like bitcoin has a limited
amount
uh and it's tied to physical you know uh
to
to proof for work so it's tied to
physical reality
in terms of how much you can mine
effectively and so on
that that's an important feature of
money do you think
that's an important feature to be a part
of
whatever the money is that is certainly
a very useful
part so um at some point in time you
know assume a veteran or
money something that all of a sudden we
say this is money i have a currency
then uh you know i offer you 10 days in
payment of
whatever goods and services you want to
provide but but
at the end of the day if you know that
uh you can cultivate it and generate
them
at will then perhaps you know you should
not accept
my payment in uh here is uh um
a bouquet of basis so you need some kind
of viscosity the inability to create a
suddenly out of nothing is uh is a is an
important and uh
um it's not that intrinsic
necessity but it's much easier to accept
once you know that there is a fixed
number of units or whatever currency
there is and therefore
you can mentally understand i'm getting
you know
this much of this piece of a pie and
therefore i consider myself
paid i understand what i'm receiving
you